make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so under normal circumstances I
would not upload two videos like this
back-to-back right because you know it's
it's something I would try to kind of
keep variety going and usually try to
space it out over the course of a week
or two but I do want to cover this while
it's still fresh in everyone's minds so
one of the big questions that came out
of the the last video that we did when
it came to Superman and and the idea of
Jonathan Kent growing older is what
happened and the interesting thing about
this is that initially Bendis didn't
really explained right like all he
really told us was that Jonathan was out
in space and he was with his granddad
and then he basically got sucked into
like a vortex more or less like a big
black hole and then ended up in a
different dimension which presumably was
earth 3 and all indications are that it
is earth 3 and that in turn like be
basically aged up and there wasn't a
whole lot of explanation there the cool
thing about this is that this story
actually gives us that now the conflict
between himself and earth 3 super woman
who is Lois Lane I mean she's an
Amazonian I guess so she's a combination
of Wonder Woman and and lowest in the
event the fight actually ends like
really fast and there's really not a
whole lot going there's not a whole lot
doing but what he really seems to
indicate here is that like Jonathan kid
was here for a period of time and then
he made his escape ran into superwoman
along the way on her three and now he's
now basically he ends up back in his own
dimension when he's rescued by his
grandfather and he's essentially like
whisked away super woman's kind of
defeated quick fast and in a hurry and
then Jonathan ends up back on the ship
again and this is when the answers start
to come in because well the questions
asked what did you see like what's been
happening Jonathan kind of spills the
beans a little bit but it's grandfathers
literally freaking out as if he hasn't
seen Jonathan for some time and that's
what he basically tells him like I
haven't seen you in years it's been I've
been searching for you for years and
years and years and so the implication
here is that when Jonathan was sucked
into the Oh basically yanked out of his
black hole and then ripped to another
dimension that what essentially happened
as he was thrown back in both time and
space and so what it basically meant is
that he's been just kind of
free-floating and it's interesting when
you when you think about this because
for the most part aside from events like
flashpoint
and maybe a couple other moments here
and there DC doesn't really invoke
time-travel in the same way that Marvel
does right like Marvel invokes
time-travel all the time and buiness
loves to do that but with this with the
idea of time travel it's almost
impossible to find somebody right like
the equivalent of trying to find someone
in spate like when they're lost in space
and time is it would be like me taking a
rock and then just like throwing it ran
in an ocean so you know in like the
Pacific Ocean somewhere and then saying
now go find it like it'd be almost
impossible for you to do that that's
what it's like trying to track somebody
down through time and space the fact
that like jor-el found Jonathan was
chance it was it was it was a pure
chance like he was talking about having
to like make all these bargains and make
all these pacts and we don't know
explicitly what they are so we're kind
of left to assume that maybe some of
these bargains of pacts he made led him
to where Jonathan was but regardless of
the situation assuming that like it was
more of information brokering like he
went that way as opposed to like travel
to this place at these coordinates to
this point in time and you will find
Jonathan that it wasn't hitting it you
hitting it on the nose then the fact
that jor-el found him which was pure
chance
it was insurmountable odds that led to
this but in in reality like from from
the whole perspective as jor-el puts it
that that basically as far as the
world's concerned Jonathan's been gone
for like a little over three weeks right
like 22 days so like three weeks in one
day he's basically been gone for that
period of time but for for Jonathan it's
been years and that's why he aged up is
because basically he was just kind of
yanked through a hole now in truth it
doesn't really work that way black holes
and in physics don't really work that
way but they are I mean it is kind of
book logic right so I mean one of the
things I learned very early on when it
comes to comic books is if what you're
expecting is a real-world physics
application the comic books you're gonna
be disappointed um but again it's it's
it's intriguing you know it's one of
these interesting things because by and
large like the whole scenario here is
that when it when it came to jor-el well
he doesn't really seem to let it honor
doesn't really say it outright he's been
struggling in a variety of ways and
really one of the big ways it seems to
be is like he's let you know he tells
Jonathan I could not go home without you
if Joelle shows up back on earth without
Jonathan in tow and the questions asked
by like Superman and Lois Lane where's
our son and he's like lost somewhere in
the sands of time in space like I would
even be worried about Superman I'd be
worried about Lois but she would lose
her mind mama bear would freak if she
found out her son was like lost out
there in space sometime probably never
to be seen or heard from again
woe betide jor-el if he goes to earth
and and breaks that bit of news there
but again it's these cool things because
one of the other half of it I guess
they're really the part of this seems to
be there like jor-el loves Jonathan like
he legitimately loves him as his
grandson right and it kind of makes
sense because when you look at the
notion of my grandparents and
grandchildren versus pairs of children
that in a lot of ways when grandparents
look at their grandchildren it's kind of
a way to at least spoil them or in some
while they're not directly raising their
grandchildren at least not under normal
circumstances to basically play a role
that allows them to kind of correct some
of the mistakes they made with their
kids right because every parent screws
up every parent makes mistakes or at
least on their own mind makes mistakes
with their kids even if they didn't
necessarily screw up at all but when it
comes to Jonathan when I'm sorry when it
comes to jewelry looking at Jonathan in
a lot of ways this kind of seems to be
like him acting out the role of a father
did he always felt like he should have
been right like taking his son under his
wing and training him and teaching him
what he needs to know in order to
understand the universe around him right
if this was not an option that jor-el
had with Superman by the time jor-el
popped back up again
Superman was long since grown up he
basically kind of established himself in
the world of the DC superhero landscape
but for Jonathan he's young he's vibrant
he's fresh he's brand-new here he's
literally in init lolis aside from a
couple smatterings of events here with
the Teen Titans and some things with his
father for the most part he's a blank
slate and so being able to take him and
throw them at him to space and say this
is the universe's as the world around
you this is how all this kind of stuff
functions this is how you reside in the
place in it this is the legacy your
father made a lot of this is jor-el
taking Jonathan under his wing and doing
the things that he wish he'd had a
chance to do with kal-el with his son
with with Clark Kent but again those
aren't really options that are there but
it's it's intriguing because when he
sits down and starts talking to him
Jonathan's response is like I need to go
home like I need to leave I need to get
back and jor-el doesn't necessarily say
no so much as you're not gonna look the
same they'll recognize you but like
it'll be a bit of a shock to them but it
really kind of seems to be jor-el like
preparing to take Jonathan back home
which again it's kind of a cool thing
but the issue with all this is that as
soon as that happens they're suddenly
met by the arrival of warships of course
you've got like General Zod but they're
led by Robles are and in turn like
Jonathan basically makes his escape or
it really kind of his suit ends up
sending him back to earth but I want to
talk about this for a second because
again this is the nature of bindus
writing and that's why when it comes to
Brian Michael Bendis people only ever
read him in one of two ways either they
read him as like as like a whole omnibus
run or they'll read it in trade uh or at
least I get I guess really the best way
to read Bendis is to read it in trade or
to read it as a whole run because when
it goes when you go issue by issue
sometimes it's kind of easy to get lost
right because where Jonathan Hickman is
kind of a master it like setting seeds
and different things like that and then
sort of building it all up that in in
Bendis writing it's very easy to get
lost you don't
have that problem with Hickman because
it all sort of ties in right like it's
event one than event two then it'd been
three that have been four and then you
get all the way down to like event
number 40 and then it all wraps back
around to event one again but it's a
cohesive story that makes sense all
along the way with Bendis is kind of
event one than event five and three then
28 and then 36 and then forth and it
just kind of bounces all over the place
and it can become like really convoluted
it tuns it's not the worst thing and
again the way that business is writing
Superman at the moment I actually I buy
a door like I absolutely love it it's
interesting it's fun it's action-packed
but this is one of the reasons why
business writing is so intriguing
because it taps back into robust arc
this is hey look this guy who was cast
into the Phantom Zone is back again we
don't know exactly how and the
assumption is that with this this
because of the fact that Jonathan
transfers back to earth so fast that
robos are made his escape now my initial
thought was well then Jonathan basically
like he encountered rubbles art before
rules are like fought Superman right
like before the unity saga storyline but
you know that doesn't really seem to be
the case instead what really seems to be
going on it's like robos are made his
escape and the reason why is because
when Superboy is essentially jettison
newly we needs teleported back to earth
more or less when he arrives back on
earth it's literally like like he
basically says like I came to find you
you know talking to talking to Superman
and Lois I came to find you as soon as I
got that here right so like what kind of
left to assume that no real time has
passed there from the time that Jonathan
showed up here on earth that it might be
minutes or maybe a day or so but
certainly probably not enough time for
Superman to like race off into space the
whole saga was Robles are to unfold then
that's it you know if there really isn't
a whole lot of time there so it's kind
of a cool thing because the response to
Superman is well then we have to deal
with this one we have to go find my
granddad or I'm sorry my father and to
like we have to deal with robos art
because he's not a villain you just
leave out there right I mean he's an
extremist he's a fanatic destroying
worlds different things like that the
idea that it suits a purpose and so on
and so forth a score suit mana Jonathan
leading into that conflict but once they
arrive to the ship of where jor-el is as
soon as they get there all hell's broken
loose you literally have like all these
forces of rogles are facing off against
all these stanag arrogance right like
the race where Hawkman and Hawk woman
derive from you've got all those all
these groups go into you know these two
groups go into war with each other and
we have no idea what set all this off
I mean the thanagarians are very much
like a kind of a a warrior race right in
like they've made kind of police their
own territory and so on and so forth but
again like like things are popping off
pretty bad and I'm kind of curious to
see what direction of this goes because
I can almost guarantee it's gonna we're
gonna see like a full invocation of the
of the Green Lantern Corps being brought
in but still you know it's a cool little
thing but I want to go ahead and throw
this out there again relatively fast in
comparison to the last video we did just
that it's still fresh in everybody's
mind and you guys get some much-needed
answers then I think a lot of you guys
were looking for but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later oh you guys said peace I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you